I think Jay talks about in the video
that he works managing other editors at
a post-production house is also an
editor as well yeah you know it's
interesting because it's one thing to
say I can't work nine to five and I know
a lot of creative people that do that
yeah and I can't work in an office for
someone else and then there's a lot of
people in LA you know they do have that
mindset yet they may never make it in
the film industry and i'm not talking
about jay's specifically i'm just
talking about people in general how do
we know or maybe there is no way to know
but the entertainment career there's no
set path it's not like I passed the lsat
you take the cbest and you're in you
know pretty much the worst path in an
entertainment career is to assume that
there's a set path and to follow that by
rote if you do that you're pretty much
definitely not going to make it but yeah
go ahead oh no it's perfect yeah I mean
but but you know and then you could do
the cliche Oh on faith you know and I'm
gonna fault you know all that but but
there's a lot of stories of people that
they never turn that corner and
unfortunately time has passed them by
and they haven't put effort into other
things yeah and then the stark reality
happens where you look around and maybe
you're not where you want to be yeah so
what if someone came to you and said
look I want to follow this entertainment
career path but there is no set path
what do i do knowing that I may never
cross over what would you won't advise
them I think the most important thing
about following an entertainment career
path is is that you can't follow a path
and and that's you know that's why I'm
supporting this project and want to be
in it it's you know my friend Jay he's
not trying to make a career move he's
the story was in him that had to come
out in it and there was nothing he could
do about it and this movie was going to
happen come hell or high water and and
and I think that's what moves people
that's what moved me to be a part of the
project and that's that's what's moving
people to support it and you know we
have all these producers who are working
on the movie for free because they feel
that energy they feel that passion they
feel the need for this thing to be born
and I would just encourage everyone
you know to not think about their career
but to think about what it is that they
want to give to the world and I think if
you think in those terms things will
unfold and everything will will will
sort of like fill in around you because
there is no path
you